hurricane elsa is threatening the rescue
effort at that collapsed condominium
tower in south florida where 126 people
remain unaccounted for that number
shrank friday when some residents who
were reported missing
turned up safe while authorities
eliminated duplicate names
22 people are confirmed dead the cause
of the collapse remains
unclear omar villafranca is in surfside
where rescue and recovery efforts are
now in their 10th day
omar good morning good morning not only
are crews worried about
the safety of the actual site and the
track of hurricane elsa
the miami herald reports that six first
responders who were working on the mound
tested positive for coronavirus they
have been isolated
and the rescue mission continues
the grueling work continues first
responders using
everything they have from their hands to
heavy machinery
on friday four more victims were
identified including the seven-year-old
daughter of a miami firefighter
the city of miami fire department has
lost
a seven-year-old daughter of one of our
own firefighters
so many of us have known someone who has
been
in the building or affected by this
tragedy colonel alad edry and his
israeli team have been working on the
mound in 12
hour shifts how hard is it after so many
days
having to see this repeatedly first of
all it's a very
tough experience for the rescuers and
working as you feel now very hot
and rainy in some parts of the day it's
very rainy
those conditions could worsen as
hurricane elsa approaches
how do your crews prepare for a possible
hurricane
at a disaster site well there's plans
being made at this time
but that include getting everybody off
the mound
it is very possible that depending on
what we
end up receiving that all work will stop
if there's a lightning strike within a
two and a half mile radius of the site
work has to stop for 30 minutes
meanwhile fear of another collapse
prompted the closure and evacuation
of this 156 unit building in nearby
north miami beach
there's a lot of elderly people in that
building they have to carry some out
today
while hurricane force winds could topple
what's left of champlain towers
the building will come down surfside's
mayor said friday
the building will be demolished in the
weeks ahead but for now
the rescue and recovery work continues
the mission is going to be the same
we are going to bring every single
person that's in that pile
back to their families it is a holiday
weekend but the city of miami beach is
cancelling its fireworks display
instead they're asking people to shine a
light to honor the victims
and the first responders dana omar i
think so many people around the country
and around the world obviously thinking
of everyone there thank you